[Musique]
danse à l'école est une action
artistique mené en milieu scolaire
initié et piloté par le prisme en
collaboration avec les enseignants et
les écoles partenaires des lampions le
résultat de cette année de travail en
commun vient d'être présenté au prisme
en présence des parents guidés par des
professionnels les enfants ont pu
exprimer à travers la danse leurs envies
et mieux comprendre le langage
chorégraphique et leur apport
[Musique]
douze classes de quatre écoles ont
participé aux 144 heures d'atelier les
enseignants quant à eux ont suivi une
formation de 12
[Musique]
ce devait être une fête
à 11h30 le personnel de la communauté
d'agglomération préparait encore les
derniers paniers repas offert aux 500
habitants de la ville nouvelle qui
avaient fait le déplacement
chacun n'avaient donc plus qu'à croiser
les doigts alors que tombaient les
résultats des comptes
[Applaudissements]
malheureusement le sprint final et
remportés par londres
un coup de trafalgar vient de s'abattre
et vous venez de l'entendre c'est une
énorme déception ici c'est londres qui
finalement vient de recevoir les
olympiades pour 2012 la 117e session
d'essai ion qu'il ne restera pas comme
un très bon souvenir pour les français
nous allons demander aux gens qui sont
venus quand même ici pour faire la
vanille ce qu'ils en pensent se compose
allait venir avec moi excusez moi
monsieur je peux vous demander quel est
votre sentiment comme ça après cette
annonce qu'est ce que vous en pensez
une déception certaine mais je vais
faire avoir au moins une personne chez
moi qui va être contente c'est mon fils
qui travaille à londres donc il va être
content mais moi je suis très déçu
chez les représentants du monde
politique et sportif la nouvelle est
aussi accueilli avec beaucoup d'amertume
le cauchemar giresse il est vain mot
c'est quelque chose qu'on peut pas
imaginer comment le le pire la pire
solution qu'on puisse imaginer en fait
il est vrai qu'on avait un bon dossier
une superbe dynamique tant au niveau de
la france et de paris qu'au niveau de 50
en guinée ces scènes communes
les habitants se sont mobilisés mais on
connaissait les règles
la fête ne s'est finalement pas prolongé
et c'est le visage crispé que les
derniers saint quentinois sont repartis
[Musique]